i guess everybody
just wants to be remembered you know
like you want to make your mark
sort i think that's like i don't really
i think about it a lot more than i
should probably but
it seems to be the goal in life right is
is like make your mark you know well
i mean here's the thing dude like
without getting too deep into it
i think that uh as human beings we're in
a [ __ ]
real jam because we got one instinct and
that is to survive
and we have one guarantee which is we're
not gonna [ __ ] survive
so the one [ __ ] thing we care about
is the one
[ __ ] it's like wait what our [ __ ]
whole
existence is a prank on us that sucks so
bad
like every instinct is to not die and we
have to go through life
knowing that we're gonna [ __ ] die
we're just barreling towards the one
[ __ ] thing that we're most afraid of
and we gotta we gotta wrap our head
around that one way or another
so there's three ways people do it they
have kids so they can say oh when i die
you know i reproduce so i got my family
lineage you know like our part of me
lives on
and then the other way is that people if
they turn to religion
man that's why religion's so [ __ ]
popular because it promises that it's
okay that you're gonna die because you
can go to heaven
and that's not me either then the third
way is i'm gonna leave some [ __ ] behind
i might be gone but the [ __ ] i leave
behind is gonna be forever
and uh yeah you and i fall into that
category very clearly
you you wanna leave your mark you wanna
you wanna be remembered for some reason
but
does it really matter when you're dead
yeah that's the funny thing too
it's not gonna matter but but it does
now dude that's why the [ __ ] cavemen
in the caves were drawing [ __ ] stick
figures because they knew
that they're gonna be dead as [ __ ] but
they're like damn this stick figure's
gonna be here forever
yeah i'm gonna skip this into this rock
and it'll be here forever
yeah dude who did it i did it
[ __ ] you know
yeah dude